on va appeler on va appeler matt pokora
tout de suite on m'appelait des gens
comme ça aussi pendant l'émission
maintenant appelé ma mère aussi
là on n'a pas de poster des nations
merci on est en direct comme d'habitude
sa deuxième sonnerie à je vous rappelle
il ya un voyage à l'île maurice a gagné
soit à l'eau matt savage 0 ouais dis moi
mon frérot tu as vu tu nous regardes ou
pas
[Rires]
0 c'est normal c'est ses huit maintenant
et ouais on a oublié le dire ma pensée
c'est 8 alors détruire ou tard regardez
l'extrait là que j'ai montré ou pas quoi
c'est vrai bon bah écoute voilà bah moi
tout et voilà on est en train de parler
de temps on voulait dire qu'on ten cate
et de vanter devant l'écran
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
non
parise
[Musique]
bon ça en house casting c'est qu'il s'en
sort bien s'agir vie salut mon pote
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
galéré votre mur je tiens prends ça pour
parler c'est 1000 par équité galéré
depuis non ça va bonsoir madame m à 13 7
les fêtes les descentes j'aimerais que
nous fasse une petite chorégraphie sur
le plateau quand nous y en a
[Applaudissements]
vous savez je vais pas venir c'est la
surprise totale
ouais elle est bonne tama - là lra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'était c'était ça le fait ça tous et
pas partie des surprises
[Musique]